gilles attaque guillaume abrite un lieu
unique à la réunion
il s'agit d'un plateau complètement
isolée sur les remparts de la rivière de
saint denis à partir de 1864
les missionnaires de la congrégation du
saint-esprit décide d'y construire une
colonie agricole pénitentiaire pour
enfants à l'image de ces maisons de
correction qui essaime partout en france
au milieu du 19e siècle à partir de 1850
en france on installe ce qu'on appelle
les maisons de correction pour éviter
aux enfants la prison donc on va mettre
en place des lieux de placement
collectif où les enfants vont travailler
vont être isolé et on pense que grâce à
ça ils vont être dressés passé
exactement ce que vont faire les
spiritains ici d'abord à la providence
puis en créant une annexe là-haut à
lille est à guillaume et on va y
ressembler des enfants placés par la
justice des enfants qu'il faut redresser
l'yvette à guillaume les enfants sont
gardés par les remparts on n'a pas
besoin du tout d'une architecture
carcérale et pour ça les lettres c'est
absolument dans le projet des maisons de
correction et puis c'est un lieu où les
enfants ont beaucoup travaillé on va
beaucoup leur faire construire des murs
des terrassements des routes un pont et
là aussi on est dans le projet intégral
des colonies agricoles pénitentiaire on
pense que par l' isolement et le travail
les enfants vont retrouver le bon chemin
c'est absolument pour le coup assez
inédit pour moi de travailler avec des
archéologues c'est à dire que là on va
vraiment mallet le travail en archives
et le travail sur le terrain pour
compléter le travail de l'historienne
sur les archives
une équipe d'archéologues sous la
direction de thierry cornec est chargé
par le département de la réunion de
réaliser une étude exhaustive des
vestiges du pénitencier pour cette
mission un peu le département a confié
l'inrap
je suis accompagné de trois spécialistes
un topographe qui assure aussi tous les
relevés de photogrammétrie un
spécialiste de l'étude du bâti qui va
nous permettre de décrypter les
différentes constructions et une
archéobotanique pour l'évolution de la
flore sur le site l'année dernière il ya
un relevé lidar qui a été réalisé sur le
site par le département donc se relever
l'état nous donne un modèle numérique
terrestre sont se dire qu'on voit le
micro relief du site le problème du
lidar c'est qui fait abstraction de ce
qui est entrepris que naturel nous avons
effectivement nous voyons des terrasses
stmicro relief nous on sait pas s'il a
été fait par la main de l'homme
naturellement donc nous notre rôle d'un
archéologue justement c'est de
différencier ce qui est naturel ce qui
en pratique aurait si vous voyez que
toutes les terrasses elle son entropie
qu'elles ont été construites par ses
enfants pendant ses 15 années
d'existence du pénitencier
les informations que je vais apporter à
mes collègues déjà un plan au sol pour
connaître les espaces de circulation se
trouvent les habitats avoir des données
de tourments métriques de mesure et puis
aussi d'avoir de leur apporter des
documents sur les élévations qui vont
permettre à des collègues
justement de travailler sur ses murs et
notamment dans la partie archéo du bâti
tout fait ludovic it in l'étude des murs
nous permet de retracer l'histoire du
site à partir de la construction et des
méthodes de construction des murs les
archives nous parle de maçon ou de
charpentier qui participait au la mise
en oeuvre du chantier mais par contre on
ne sait pas à quelle hauteur les enfants
ont travaillé ils ont pu participer à la
construction de bâtiments de moindre
importance on va dire comme par exemple
la chapelle où la forge ou l'utilisation
des blocs plus petit est utilisée ou
alors au dallage on sait qu'ils ont
participé au chemin d'accès et à la
voirie principale ce mieux quand il
était il était en utilisation par les
enfants du pénitencier
on sait qu'il y avait de l'agriculture
parce que il vivait un petit peu en
autonomie donc on a des témoignages des
sources marchive qui nous dise qu'il y
avait une agriculture
le but maintenant c'est de pouvoir
vraiment
la caractériser est-ce que c'était une
grosse et agriculture intensive d'une
seule espèce est ce que c'était plein de
petites espèces différentes pour
répondre à cette question je vais faire
des prélèvements surtout donc je creuse
des sondages des petits sondages dans
lesquels je prélève du sédiment ces
sédiments ils sont amusés et je vais
rechercher les graines et les charmants
aux priorités
donc ça ça va me permettre de pouvoir
dire bon à tel endroit où j'ai prélevé
on avait telles espèces telles espèces
cas d'espèce
ces trois disciplines se complètent pour
dessiner l'évolution des différentes
constructions en proposant des
chronologie relative des murs en
déterminant leur mode de construction la
mise en commun du travail des
archéologues permet de mieux comprendre
la destination de chacun des espaces
logement atelier lieux de culte
bassecourt vergers mais aussi voirie
canaux et bassins nécessaires à la
gestion de l'eau captée par la
communauté en amont du site
donc on a tous les éléments nécessaires
à la bonne compréhension du site et
surtout de s'apercevoir qu'ils à des
pleins pleins de choses de inédites
qu'on ne connaissait pas qu'ils avaient
été vus mais mal interprété ou pas
interpréter du tout donc au titre des
nouveautés qui
voilà qu'on a découvert grâce à notre
travail d'essentiellement de nettoyage
du site le fond probablement de la
basse-cour pourquoi c'est une basse cour
puisque sur creusé dans cette danse est
terrasse on a un bassin
pourquoi c'est interprété comme un
bassin deux éléments les murs qu'on a
devant nous sont enduits pour rendre les
parois et sans doute le fond étanche et
puis surtout sur la droite du bassin
dans la paroisse un petit peu effondré
ici on a on a un exutoire qui permettait
d'amener l'eau à cet endroit du site
au dessus on a à nouveau une allée de
circulation et puis encore au dessus on
a le dernier élément d'un grand bâtiment
qui était considéré comme une partie du
logement de la communauté et à
l'extrémité les murs en élévation qui
sont cette fois ci contrairement aux
autres maçonné monter au mortier de
chaux
c'est très très probablement ce que dans
les archives on a découvert comme étant
la chapelle provisoire avant la
construction de l'église qui est
construite à lens tenu du plateau
la perspective principale en fête du
travail à venir c'est de croiser les
résultats de l'étude de terrain avec
l'étude historique de vernis blanchard
de façon à approcher au plus près la vie
des spiritains et des enfants du
pénitencier lille est à guillaume
pendant la quinzaine d'années ils ont
vécu ici pour aller plus loin et
conformément à la mission confiée par le
département de la réunion
l'inrap va proposer des fouilles
sédimentaires sur des thématiques
particulières comme les logements de la
communauté afin d'approcher un peu plus
le quotidien des enfants et des
spiritains du pénitencier dilate à
guillaume qui n'a pas fini de livrer
tous ses secrets
à partir des résultats de cette étude le
département la réunion va pouvoir en
concertation avec les habitants
définir un projet de préservation et de
valorisation de ces vestiges pour le
rendre accessible à tous les réunionnais
eo2 l'homme
bon
[Musique]